you can change a person's shoes Esther a
guy's wearing those and you're fine that
shoe is you cannot bounce back to
there's a thing in your head that
thought that was okay that I can't get
on board with's nothing what about guys
who have Pat who have leather Chelsea
boot I used to like you're gay you are
gay now I know you're gay that I
can't this is like I cannot I'm like I
don't know what is going on in your life
that allowed you to do this that is that
is Russell Brand that is guy who's like
that is Russell Brand yeah that is Russ
BR it's a guy who has like a ponytail
and he like wears linen all the time and
he like he says stuff like oh I want you
to be a part of my tribe that's a fedora